tentez le gouvernement en tout cas
cherche à éviter le scénario de l'été
2003 où ses services avaient été prises
en défaut la canicule avait fait quinze
mille morts
pour l'instant ce mot de canicule n'est
pas encore prononcé mais le dispositif
de prévention pour cet été et est
présenté aujourd'hui sophie rodier
pierre brand joseph nous sommes en
recherche de personnes qui seraient
susceptibles d'être isolé des personnes
âgées
il a encore fait plus de 30 degrés cet
après midi en alsace dans les rues de
sélestat la police municipale patrouille
traquer l'isolément c'est l'un des
principes du plan présenté ce matin un
plan qui se décline en quatre points
niveau 1 la veille saisonnière chaque
jour du 1er juin au 1er octobre
météo france publie une carte des
départements les plus chauds niveau 2
c'est la préalerte déclenché trois jours
avant une vague de chaleur niveau 3
la vague de chaleur et largue celle
alerte les hôpitaux et les maisons de
retraite se tiennent prêts enfin niveau
4 la mobilisation maximale en cas de
canicule
les pompiers l'armée et les hôpitaux
peuvent être réquisitionnés
mais avant d'en arriver là le
gouvernement en appelle à la solidarité
des français avons demandé à tous les
acteurs toutes les personnes qui sont au
quotidien avec ces personnes âgées ces
personnes plus fragiles de dialoguer de
passer ce message des messages très
clairs protégez-vous de la chaleur
l'expérience dramatique du mois d'août
2003 semblent avoir été prises en compte
14800 47 morts en deux semaines pour la
plupart des personnes âgées qui vivait
seul
cette année xavier bertrand reconduit
les 26 millions d'euros de crédits
exceptionnels qui devrait permettre de
recruter des personnels saisonniers sont
retrouve aujourd'hui en début d'été 2005
dans la même situation que nous avons
connue au début de l'été 2004
c'est-à-dire les ministres sont obligés
d'annoncer des mesures provisoires dans
l'urgence pour pallier les manques en
juillet et en août les professionnels
venant d'une conférence nationale sur
l'aide aux personnes vj en france 10
millions de personnes ont plus de 65 ans